Some of the Things You Missed in this trailer
point to this being the darkest Purge movie
yet.
If you want to see what I mean, then stick
around to the end of this video.
One of the things that's always left me wanting
more with the Purge movies is that they're
so focused on murder.
I mean come on, the rules of the Purge state
that all crime will be legal for 12 hours.
I mean sure, there's that girl who wants to
steal a candy bar or whatever in Election
Year, but where are all the vandals, trespassers,
kidnappers, drug doers and other criminals
that don't involve murder?
In my mind, that's the fun stuff that I'd
want to be doing on Purge night.
It looks like this prequel may help explain
why we don't see a lot of that stuff in subsequent
Purges.
One of the first images we see is this chick
on a swing in an industrial looking building.
If you pause you'll see she's in a high voltage
area.
And a lot of the other images we see from
the beginning of this First Purge, just seem
to be young people blowing things up, doing
shenanigans, and even just holding crazy parties
in the street with no consequences.
None of them seem to have very malicious intent.
So the President, and this woman who came
up with the idea for the Purge, are monitoring
these activities, and the President seems
disappointed that more people aren't getting
violent.
"Parties?
You predicted a much higher level of participation."
Because remember, one of the main conspiracies
from the three existing Purge films is that
The Purge is just a way for the government
to clean up their streets by killing off the
poor, who are the ones who are most vulnerable
during The Purge.
In order to go through with this agenda, the
President tampers with the experiment by artifically
introducing murder into the equation.
"You're sending soldiers into the island disguised
as citizens?"
This President is corrupt, and he's using
this Staten Island Purge experiment as a front
for the American public to convince them that
the Purge is helping the country, so that
he can get what he wants.
The New Founding Fathers of America, or the
NFFA, are the political party that supports
the Purge, and this President is most likely
their first member to gain power.
He even replaces the United States coat of
arms flag in the oval office with this flag,
which looks to have the last two letters from
the acronym NFFA along with a preliminary
version of the logo.
He also wears an NFFA pin right next to his
American flag.
There's evidence that he's going to be manipulating
The Purge in more ways than one.
Since this Purge is just an experiment, it's
outcome could greatly affect the possibility
of the future country-wide Purges taking place.
And since this one just takes place in the
isolated environment on Staten Island, the
President is gonna want to be able to control
the perception of the experiment by the rest
of the American people.
Throughout the trailer there are these broadcasts
by a channel called CNB, which is mostly likely
a play on CNN, which stands for cable news
network, so I imagine CNB stands for Cable
News Broadcast or something.
Throughout the trailer, they are the only
ones who are covering to the events of the
Purge, including live broadcasts from inside
the Purge and propaganda to convince the public
that there is no political agenda behind the
controversial holiday.
"Is The Purge a political device?"
"It is a psychological one.
If we want to save our country we must release
all our anger in one night."
Seeing as how The Purge movies have tied themselves
in with current political movements in America,
I wouldn't be surprised if this CNB network
took a page out of CNNs book and became involved
in some fake news allegations.
They could even be a pawn of the NFFA used
to make the American think what their government
wants them to think.
Of course, there's always going to be backlash,
which brings us to our main character.
It seems like she's already a rebellious voice
in her community.
Before the announcement of The Purge, she's
already got this megaphone, which we later
see her use at the Purge protests.
The protests have some interesting signage.
We see more references to the current real
life American political standing, like this
Not My Purge sign, which is a parody of the
Not My President signs held by opposers of
current US President Donald Trump.
There's also a sign that says "We Are Not
Gun Lab Rats", "NFFA Murder" and if you skim
through frame by frame, you can see this sign
in the background that says, "The 28th is
a HA", which most likely says "The 28th is
a HATE CRIME."
So what does this mean?
Currently the USA has a Constitution with
27 amendments, or 27 rules.
In this movie, it looks like The Purge will
become the 28th amendment, so there's a little
bit of insight on how the Purge came to be
recognized by the US government.
And then saying that it's a hate crime means
that it's a violent act motivated by prejudice,
in this case, an act created to wipe out the
lower class.
Sending soldiers in to tamper with the experiment
may not be the only suspicious activity the
President is up to though.
At the location where the President and Dr.
Updale are interviewed by CNB, you can pause
and read the sign in the background.
If you combine this shot with another screenshot
where the sign is present, you can put the
two together to read: Want to make $5,000?
Participate in the Staten Island Experiment.
No experience.
No background checks.
No drug testing.
something something NFFA.
I have a two theories about what this job
could entail.
This could just be a call for more mercenaries
to send into the Purge and incite violence.
In this trailer we see more traditional looking
soldiers, and these creepy looking fighters
who also seem to be a part of organized units.
It's possible the president is sending two
opposing armed groups into the Purge on orders
to kill each other, with no knowledge that
the other has been hired.
This would naturally cause them to get into
a huge battle and help prove the NFFA's point
that violence has been pent up inside of everyone
and needs to be released.
My other theory is that the NFFA is targeting
the poor, and trying to send homeless people
from across the country into Staten Island
for The Purge.
They would probably be the most desperate
and likely to risk their lives for such a
small sum on money, and it would help the
supposed agenda of the NFFA trying to clean
up the streets.
Remember in the other movies, the NFFA and
their rich supporters almost take the killing
of homeless people as a religious ritual.
In Election Year, they even hold the ceremonious
killings in a church.
This new trailer suggests even more of a religious
side to the Purge than we've seen before.
"Tonight we'll see the good and evil in everyone."
There's actually a ton of evidence in this
trailer that the Purge is somehow tied into
Satanism.
So I'm gonna run through and point out what
I noticed, feel free to leave your own ideas
in the comments.
In other Purge movies we've seen creepy masks
of American symbols like Uncle Sam and the
Statue of Liberty.
In this movie, the masks look more demonic.
There's a Pentagram on the wall right here.
One of the signs in the protest accuses the
government of turning Staten Island into "Satan
Island."
And then on the other side of that shot, a
man holds a sign reading "Rise Above", which
seems to be the counterbalance to the Satan
Island sign.
When the experiment begins, there are a lot
of people hiding out in what appears to be
a church.
Pause right here.
There's a battle that goes on at the intersection
of Genesee and Ivy.
I looked it up in Google Maps and that's the
location of a Baptist Church.
If you pause here there's yet another church
in the background.
And at the end of the trailer we can see these
guys, who are also in the previous film, may
be involved as well.
But, at the beginning of this video when I
said there is something really dark going
on in this trailer, I wasn't even talking
about the Satanism.
It looks like there's actually a group out
there targeting kids.
There's a scene of these women using a child's
furniture to barricade a room and there's
a scene where a Teddy bear is wired with explosives.
If you look closely you'll notice there is
a whole alley full of children's toys rigged
up to explosives, including baby dolls, teddy
bears and more.
It looks like maybe the rule seen in the other
3 movies that bans class 4 explosives hasn't
been introduced yet, this may be the reason
that that rule is added.
This next one could be a really cool reference
or just a coincidence, let me know your thoughts
on it.
This rich guy has a pool table, with a few
balls left out.
If the pool cue represents a slash, then the
balls spell out 3 / 12, 10.
Twelve plus 10 is 22.
3/22 is March 22nd, the date that the Purge
ends each year.
It could mean that this guy wants to see the
Purge end once and for all.
And my last Thing You Missed from this trailer
is actually just the title cards scattered
throughout.
At first they appear to be bandages, and as
the video goes on they become more and more
stained with blood, until the end of the trailer
where they have now become the stripes of
the American flag, suggesting that the identity
of the countries is now stained with blood.
This has been a crazy video week, I already
released two Things You Missed earlier in
the week on Cargo and A Quiet Place, so make
sure you check those out if you haven't already.
And make sure you're prepared for The Purge
this year by subscribing to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week and I will see you in the
next one.
Assuming, we both survive.